and that conjuring universe is split now
movies even compared to other franchises
I'm including myself in this when I say
people out there who are like [ __ ] too
many Star Wars movies but conjuring
movies who cares Annabelle Annabelle
comes home is the newest Annabelle movie
in how many conjuring movies have there
been or conjuring universe movies have
there been there have been a lot
Annabelle is part of that whole universe
Annabelle comes home as a third
Annabelle movie and Patrick Wilson and
Vera Farmiga who played the Warrens
they're in it briefly they're like hey
this is our house and in our house is a
room I'm just gonna call the super nerd
room of death it's straight-up like the
basement in Cabin in the woods
just everything around there don't touch
anything and if you touch something
something to come in life and kill you
anyhow the warrants leave they're like
hey teenage babysitter you want to
babysit our daughter in a house that
houses the super nerd room of death what
can go wrong
well things go wrong man I don't know if
this is something going wrong or very
right but I just enjoyed this movie a
lot more than I thought I would I get it
like after my Slenderman review people
were like [ __ ] this guy his view of
horror movies and you're probably right
I don't know what I'm supposed to say
like a good critic all I can tell you is
how I view it I honestly I had fun with
it I mean an element of fun I'm not
saying the movies not cliche as hell cuz
it is here's the premise a babysitter
the kid the babysitter's babysitting and
the babysitter's friend all come into
this house the house housing the super
nerd room of death and then demons come
out to start terrorizing yeah it sounds
pretty 90s that's kind of what I liked
about it this movie definitely does kind
of throwback to those 90s horror movies
because it does feel like a 90s horror
movie and 90s horror movies feel
different than before movies now the
only thing that keeps this from being a
true 90s horror movie is it takes itself
a bit too seriously if it had snappy or
dialogue it would definitely be a movie
that's right at home in the 90s as it
stands it tries to take itself about as
seriously as a horror movie feels it
needs to take itself a 2019 some of the
scenes could definitely you're like you
could have sliced it up but you could
have shortened that it's just it's a
person walking around a room and it's
setting up tone it actually does pretty
well setting up tone but I couldn't help
but feel like alright keep going just
shave 30 seconds 30 seconds of a person
walking around a room could feel like
five minutes like if I just took 30
seconds to go this what 30 seconds feels
like
and clocked it for 30 seconds you tune
out you go somewhere else that's what 30
seconds of downtime can do ever since
we're boyfriend figure if you like this
old boyfriend or crush whatever you want
to call him I feel like he was added in
post or something like they were like
the movies done we need a boyfriend
figure or at least someone someone has a
crush on I don't know well can we film
around it can we just do reshoots and
then add him in here and there I think
we could do that we're really just kind
of shows up does something leaves shows
up just somebody runs away that said
what I had fun with in this movie was
the horror stuff actually has a pretty
fun horror element in here and it's not
just one demon there are a few things
they have to deal with in here so if you
think one demons lying but like I'm not
really feeling that one there are others
which also lends itself to a variety of
schemes these demons are doing but it
was all going down at the end it was
actually pretty intense the audience was
having fun with it because in the end
Annabel comes home and personally
surprised me I was gonna have like 4
percent on Rotten Tomatoes don't give a
[ __ ] the first half was a bit slow the
premise is cliche [ __ ] it's a cliche
horror movie that does show love for
horror movies people make idiotic
decisions there's one demon in
particular I'm like that might be a
little bit ridiculous yeah it's about a
doll in a room full of really haunted
stuff and demons start coming after
these people one demon in particular
that's where I draw the line I guess but
if I'm supposed to enjoy myself in a
movie like this I enjoyed myself in this
movie it wasn't quite that 90s horror
movie that lends itself to being a cult
classic or anything but as a 90's horror
fan I enjoyed it nonetheless and I will
say Annabelle comes home was a good time
no alcohol acquired alright so Annabelle
comes home have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite
horror movie after the 90s that kind of
throws back to the 90s whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]